continuous seismic data a vital input to
measure earthquakes it is monitored
processed and assessed in real time here
at the Turkish disaster management
agency
turkey has sits on five major seismic
fault lines risking 71 percent of its
population and 66 percent of its
landscape the largest of those triggered
two strong earthquakes on Monday causing
death and destruction in the east
[Music]
and while we're speaking we're shaken
twice by tremors above 4.0 magnitude
this is part of life here now
aftershocks over 3.5 to 4 magnitudes
even up to six will continue for much
longer we are reevaluating the magnitude
dimensions and the affected area of the
earthquake in line with the information
from our field teams what we see is a
much bigger disaster than we anticipated
this means the damage structures can
still collapse while other risks like
snow fall await the earthquake hit areas
this line map shows all earthquakes that
have occurred since Monday's devastating
Tremors just in 15 hours on Saturday
turkey has experienced 330 earthquakes
and the country has been jolted
2356 times since what the Turkish
president called the disaster of the
century
no need to be stunned or exaggerate by
saying this is the biggest Shake we won
that 7.4 magnitude was approaching to
this area no one paid attention
as scientists say you can't resist
nature but build earthquake resistant
cities a joint responsibility of the
state people and the local
Administrations